so we're letting Mirabelle see herself a
virtual self that we can transform so we
can transform it in its posture how
relaxed it is you can see Maribel
sitting up we could make it so that the
legs are sticking out we can transform
it in its gender and how big it is and
here at the next plank we do a lot of
that so we study what it would be like
to have a larger BMI or a smaller BMI so
how do you experience the world if all
of a sudden you look down and you've
lost a few kilograms or pounds right
stones whatever human we can use virtual
realities and make people see what it's
like to be a different person but we can
also do things that are really
impossible so a lot of times what we do
here is we transform the hand so that
the hand is just a lot bigger and then
we can understand the relationship
between your own body size and the way
you perceive the world around you but
what Mirabelle is experiencing is we're
letting her look at herself in the face
right so she can actually use this as a
hand mirror this tracked object and look
and see what her face looks like and
that's really awesome because though
headsets today are really impressive
they have a little bit of a low field of
view so if you look at a girl in a
mirror that's you know out to the
distance that the mirror is here then
you don't see the face so well but here
she can bring the mirror right up to her
face and she sees a really nice
resolution face and this avatar that
she's seeing here is the average female
from a database of a large number of
humans that have been body scanned
they've done that here in Germany as
well as at the Brown University and
they've taken really tens of thousands
of people and done a 3d body scan and
then they do amazing research where they
can actually put them all into a
register scan so if they scan to me and
you they would be able to understand
exactly the shape difference that turns
me into you right how to morph me into
you and exactly what makes a person look
male and what makes them look female
yeah it's I mean it's really impressive
large-scale data actually so they do a
lot of research with that what we
benefit from from that work is that we
can actually manipulate the way people
look so we have research right now which
is what I said before where we can take
advantage of that database and really
plausibly make me fatter so not just
make me have more fat but actually model
mathematically what I would look like if
I gained a certain amount of BMI which
is really awesome research so
unfortunately we can't change the BMI of
her but we can change her to a male many
people that demo in our lab we ask them
do you want to be a male or a female and
so many of them say the opposite gender
that they are because obviously in the
real world you can't so quickly and
easily and what's cool about what she's
seeing is and capability that we have is
that we can do all this motion tracking
right you walk him talked about that
right now we're just using inverse
kinematics so that she can really see
her avatars hand move us as her hand
moves and research really shows that's
called visual motor synchrony it shows
that when you can actually see your body
moving visually as it is physically that
you have a really strong experience of
that being your body right even if it
looks different than you in this case
it's a male if it was a very large
person or the skin color was different
people still take ownership over it and
it's a fascinating tool then because you
can really research as our collaborator
Mao Slater has done a lot of how
people's attitudes change when they
become a different race or a different
gender what we do as well as we put
people into a full-body motion capture
suit and then they can really walk
around freely move and they see that
avatar move as they do because we've
really in the past had a lot of people
have a rejection of that and say that's
not me but it comes out of an experience
of wait what if that was me right and
they want to express but wait a minute
that's not that's not who I am that's
not perfectly me and it's very often
when they look at the face
so especially what I was talking about
before they see their body it's moving
and they think oh that's me and then
when we give a large mirror and they
look they say but wait that's not me
so there is sort of a idea that this is
you in the virtual world you know you
don't always want to be you when you're
on the airplane and you're a six-foot
guy you don't want to be there you don't
want to be a super tall guy in an
airplane so maybe you want to become
really small or if you're older and
you're tired and you just want to
remember what it was like to be young
and someone can offer you that
experience say hey here's the younger
you yeah that's what this technology
could enable people to have and why not
let the airplanes give it to us right
when you're flying you're exhausted why
not have a rejuvenating experience of
what it's like to be young or smaller
you know how how often someone who's big
probably looks at me and says oh man I
wish I had her short legs right when
they're in the airplane and that's the
only time I'm happy to have my shortly
but so it's really powerful what you can
give people
yeah and that's something we really it's
important for us here is really to build
into the environment the person can
really say hey I want to be this person
or I want to be in this environment and
they get to say they want to be in the
mountains they want to be at the sea
they want to be in a bigger space I mean
some people are afraid of flying and so
they might not like to be in a bigger
space they might certainly not like to
be in the clouds right so maybe what
they'd like to do is be back in their
room in a small confined space that is
calming and so you can't really make the
assumption that everybody wants this big
open space when they're in an airplane
maybe they want it to be cozy and maybe
without all the other people do you have
many people who yeah so we're really
mostly lucky in fact that's exactly what
we're studying the experiment that's
running right now with the cyber motion
simulator is exactly asking whether or
not and to what degree people get sick
and what we've had in the past is
typically if you have people walking in
this room the most time people have
gotten sick is when they're walking in
this room and our scientists are miss
mapping the way they're walking so they
walk forward and the world is spinning
around them right so because this motion
sickness mostly comes from a Mis mapping
or if we're trying to do it perfectly it
comes from the fact that you can
accelerate your head really fast and
then the tracking has a very challenging
job of making that work perfectly right
so this is where I think most people get
sick we have the luxury that we if
anybody says they're feeling sick or
they look a little pale we just stop the
experience right
but for via hyperspace we really want to
see how long people can experience it
and enjoy it right so I'm a lucky person
I don't get that sick but still the
question arises could I be in a headband
a display for two hours or three hours
right and what would be the consequences
right to my physical health not just
motion sickness and our partners again
at Barcelona are looking into that
because obviously you'd want to be
moving a little bit right because if
you're just sitting there even watching
a movie you start to feel a little sick
right so we're trying to integrate some
tools in to get people moving and to
make sure we have an awareness of their
sickness and another thing that we're
doing there is measuring their heart
rate and measuring how much they're
sweating because these things might give
us an indicator even
or you knew that you started to feel
sick hey let's back off the experience
or have him start moving more slowly
because that might prevent motion
sickness so the work from Barcelona our
colleague Elena coca Nara she does some
really amazing work where the idea is is
that you could maybe move really a lot
in the virtual world but only in reality
moving like this right so that you could
still move in your seat but you
experience your virtual self as really
moving like Superman right moving really
fast through the space and that really
works if you move just a small amount
and you see that hand reaching really
far or if you move your legs just a
little bit and you're walking through
the space people like that that's a
natural interface right and so that's
something that's important to us because
we don't want people to use VR and then
ultimately be in more pain we want more
comfort over all
real challenge but really interesting to
see what you can do in terms of changing
people's environments to increase their
comfort